all right today we are going to be
speaking with senior advisor
for the joe biden for president campaign
cristobal alex
who uh has worked on uh you've been
working on campaigns for a long time i
mean
you're not new to this that's right i'm
a bit of an old timer you can tell from
my grades i've had a
a couple of these campaigns behind me
i'm of yejito they call me
in the campaign so let's i want to talk
let's start maybe by talking about the
latino vote i've been speaking
on my show but also with my audience
over on my spanish language show
on the estrella network about the latino
vote and the growing importance
demographically of the latino vote in
the united states
i was slightly disappointed but not
altogether surprised
that a higher share of the latino vote
did not go to joe biden now i know that
there's a number of ways that we could
spin this we could look at specific
states we could look at
sort of the range of of the vote
of the latino vote that typically goes
to the republican candidate and
certainly what donald trump got is
within that range but
is there any disappointment on your side
that it was not um
an even more overwhelming victory for
joe biden among that group
you know i'll say that we're very proud
of
the work of the campaign and all of the
work that
preceded the campaign in critical
battleground states
around the country decades of organizing
work uh
from young people from immigration
rights organizations to
puerto rican organizations to others
that have led to this
election which i think is a uh an
important moment if you look at
the trajectory of building latino
political power i think
we're approaching a high water mark and
yes uh the latino community as
as you know better than anybody is is
not a monolith and so
we do want to look more specifically at
data from
states or even within states and you
know when we set out
in the general election with our latino
program
we set a goal to match the high water
mark of the 2012
obama binding re-election campaign that
hit 71 percent
of the latino vote we are just about
there as
as the numbers are are calculated and
tabulated we're at about
70 71 range right now in some of the
more crucial
uh uh uh battleground states that's
nationally if you look at some of the
if you drill down a little bit you look
at a place like wisconsin for example
where we had a hundred thousand plus
latino vote turnout
in those places latinos uh really
exceeded that
hitting almost 80 percent if you look at
maricopa county when we
flipped arizona or in pima county you're
looking at over 80 percent some places
85 percent
of the of the vote it's also the reason
why
um you know we kept we flipped arizona
that's why we kept
nevada that's why we elected a united
states senator latino united states
senator
uh in new mexico uh and and if you look
at pennsylvania
a huge surge of latino voters a lot of
borico a lot of puerto ricans there and
again
because of the hard work that preceded
the campaign and
and proudly i will say because of the
campaign significant investments over
100 million dollars
uh to reach latino voters you know we
exceeded uh
almost that 80 mark in pennsylvania
again proving to be the margin of
difference we're very excited about that
yeah okay good so those are some good
examples i mean let's let's now talk
about one
that that's an area of concern to me
we've known for a long time that
uh while the the american latino voter
community is not a monolith uh one of
the it is a very
left uh community in total with the
notable exception of cuban americans and
we know about this sort of anti-castro
reflexive thing
and fears of so-called socialism which
will often influence particularly
florida cuban americans to vote
at higher levels for republicans than
than we see in other states
it would be huge would it not to be able
to
bring over more of that cuban-american
community in florida because
with without florida the map for
republic republicans nationally
gets systemically very very difficult
and i'm wondering
what you think it will take to bring
over more cuban-american voters
that's a great question you know i'll
start by saying uh
you know miami-dade um and and south
florida
um a true battleground and we uh we
fought
very hard and competed for every single
voter uh there and and uh you know we we
did win
uh by a good margin the latino vote in
florida we've got some work to do
uh with with cubans and also venezuelans
and others
and if you look a little deeper i think
you know
president-elect did very well with
younger voters uh young latino voters
especially those were
very high uh vote share for us
but we've got some work to do with some
of the older voters especially the cuban
voters and
you know i'll say it's hard to compare
this election to 2016 when
secretary clinton got a lot of support
from the cuban community part of the
reason for that was
if you remember the the the presidential
primary in 2016 on the republican side
donald trump spent a lot of time uh
attacking marco rubio for example
among other things that that brought
down his percentage uh among cuban
voters but as you pointed out that
um usually a higher percent goes
republican there so
we are going to do some work there and i
think part of it we'll see
um trending in our direction very soon
is
um you know once a president-elect joe
biden
and and takes office along with his vice
president kamala harris
we're going to do a lot of work to make
sure that we can expand democracy
uh in cuba uh that we strengthen
relationships
uh throughout latin and central america
and make sure that we're doing the
things that we need to do
uh uh that will eventually uh again this
is going to be good policy
but eventually we'll yield uh better
percentages
in some of these communities when we
look at the politics of it
yeah you you mentioned that this year
donald trump was not
attacking marco rubio in the way that he
was in 2016. one of the other
differences i noticed and i wonder if
you if you think this is relevant
electorally
is that merely by chance not because
donald trump's views have become more
enlightened but merely by chance
there was much less discussion about
mexican rapists and criminals in the
last six months there was much less
discussion about the wall although at
rallies trump would say
the wall is being built and mexico is
paying for it obviously both lies
by by sheer distraction it seems from
what's been going on
trump did less of that and i'm wondering
if that
also ended up helping him a little bit
in the end
yeah that's a great question i've
wondered that myself and you know
i i did expect a lot more of the typical
uh vitriol demagoguing latino
communities especially immigrants
and it was there no doubt uh just not um
on the front page or the first thing out
of his mouth uh that we would see in
2018 or in 2016
right you know part of the reason for
that uh is is
undoubtedly the fact that uh our country
is facing
uh a pandemic uh and the economy is
is is in bad shape again because of
donald trump's failed leadership and
that was top of mind
for voters and he tried very hard no
doubt to to try and make the election
anything about himself or his failed
leadership
um but at the end it becomes a
referendum um
on his handling of covid his complete
and utter
failure there and so it was hard for him
to uh to turn that script
now i will say uh even though he spoke
uh perhaps less about immigrants uh
and and didn't attack latinos and
immigrants as much
as he did previously his administration
wasted no time
trying to to do harm uh to the
communities and
one of the first things that you will
see uh president-elect when he becomes
president
joe biden do is undo much of the harm
that donald trump and his administration
has done yeah so i want to talk about
that next so let's get into that we
we've started to see this list of d
possible day one executive orders
we've heard about getting back in the
who paris climate
trans military ban maybe something can
be done in terms of the trade
relationship with china via executive
order
and there's this question mark around
daca and and dreamers
what is the the day one plan what can be
done via executive order with that
program
quite a bit uh actually our new uh chief
of staff white house chief of staff ron
plain
uh last week talked about some of those
day one priorities and
uh one of those uh is very important to
joe biden
uh and kamala harris uh is
protecting dreamers so there will be
executive action
on day one um and there will also be um
an immigration bill uh that includes uh
obviously dreamers
and and and their families and and a
pathway
to citizenship a roadmap to citizenship
for the 11 million undocumented in this
country that's
that's going to happen uh right away uh
now of course we're going to have to do
a lot of work to get the immigration
bill passed but through executive action
there's going to be a very swift
undertaking to protect to protect
dreamers
yeah i i think that if democrats don't
take the senate
tax reform and the health care expansion
that joe biden wants to do
i think they don't happen i do think
that because
um some of these immigration issues are
actually relevant to some republican
senators
i i think that the chance of doing
something on immigration is
slightly higher if them even without
having the senate but a lot is riding on
those
races in georgia isn't it a lot's riding
on those races
and what i will say is um we're hopeful
uh and again you saw georgia uh turning
blue you're seeing
a record enthusiasm a record vote there
very diverse
electorate all of those things uh bode
well
but i i think it's important to remember
joe biden
has a very distinguished public service
career in the senate
he knows how to work across the aisle to
get big things done
for america whether that was um beating
the nra not once but twice
pushing for the very first climate
change legislation when he was in the
senate
whether that was advocating and getting
past the violence against women's act i
mean the list goes on and on
he does very well in these situations i
mean health care
again uh the aca another prime example
of him
uh working hard uh uh and and being able
to
to get things done with democrats and
with republicans and so
you can expect from major pieces of
legislation like that
for joe biden to do what he does best
which is to to work with others to unify
not just our country but to but to unify
our government to tackle these major
challenges
yeah i don't doubt for a second joe
biden's ability
willingness and interest to do that uh i
just think it's naive to think these
republicans are going to participate in
anything that doesn't
obviously and completely benefit uh what
what they've
laid out as their priorities i think the
republican party has changed
dramatically but
i remain cautiously optimistic my i
think the concern among some in the
progressive left
is what would joe biden have to
compromise in order to get some of these
republicans on board
you know i here's the thing i
as a progressive myself you know i think
what
what we need to remember here is
the country is on this precipice right
now
uh as joe biden talked about this uh
during the campaign
in our darkest times uh our nation has
been able to come together
and and achieve the greatest good uh
if you look at some of the moments in
history whether it's coming out of the
great depression whether it's coming out
of world war ii
uh um we're able to to
to come together and and do amazing
things um
and i know it sounds naive but i am
uh optimistic that we are at one of
these moments now where we're gonna have
to do
um we're gonna have to number one get
this pandemic the virus under control
but then
there's an opportunity uh and partly
because we have to
to rebuild this economy and there are a
lot of major components that will go
into that
including uh major investments uh again
we're going to work uh with republicans
and
and conservatives and progressives and
independents
and and all americans to get this done
but we need to be able to rebuild the
economy we need to make sure that we get
climate change
under control uh and there's ways where
we can
uh build millions of jobs in this
country that are that are green jobs and
so that's part of it that's one of the
things we need to do and the other is
you know with all of the uh the the the
racial justice issues that are now
getting
uh a lot of the attention that they that
they deserve uh there's gonna be a way
to address some of these systemic
uh racial issues in our country again uh
even though we're dealing with this
pandemic and having to rebuild this
economy there are opportunities within
that to address some of these things and
yeah i mean no uh no no disagreement for
me in terms of the stakes or the
priorities
um skepticism significant skepticism
about
the current republican party as uh as a
participant in that uh but but we we
will we will very soon start to see how
it plays out we've been speaking
with christo alex who is a senior
advisor
for the joe biden for president campaign
i really appreciate your time today
oh it was an honor thanks for having me